welcome everyone to the workshop about
what is it neural networks for images
and audio understand this is a difficult
workshop eh it's not right after lunch
but it's during lunch so I hope we'll
acquire more people while we go secondly
we have a very limited time only so we
start here right on time
this is a workshop that is pretty much
stuffed first with audio and it's gonna
be the first half of the workshop and
then was images will have a slight
difference in style in those two
workshops Carlo will start with audio
and I think he will do a more
conservative approach by explaining how
to do things now I'll do the second part
by the way my name is Marcus manasik
I'll talk about images and I want to
talk so much about how you do image
processing with neural networks in
Mathematica because we have done this
before so would start to get boring I'll
rather explain why certain things work
well and what other things don't work
well and what may be the solution in the
future so it's going to be a more
disruptive talk with good and bad stuff
in there and we'll see how it works is
the kind of a test run all right yes and
I work on audio processing and a little
bit of neural networks in machinery and
today I will talk about the connection
between neural networks and audio
signals the main topics I'm going to be
talking about is first starting how to
build a very simple audio classifier
it's it will be a small network on a toy
data set but the techniques there you
can use definitely extensible to bigger
problems then a simple example of audio
event detection and then another example
of townsville learning so let's start
with the audio classifier all we need to
start is labelled data and a network as
for labeled data we will use the spoken
digit commands data set which is in our
Reserve System it is essentially the
equivalent of amnesty it's a collection
of recordings of people speaking the
digits from 0 to 9 and it's labeled both
with the number that the digit that is
spoken and the identity of the person
for this specific classifier work we
will completely ignore the identity of
the person we will focus on what is
spoken so the idea is to classify the
digits independently on who the speaker
is so this is a random sample of the
data set let's see if audio works
properly 3 3 1 as you can see there is a
lot of variety in recording methods
people have contributed this with an
open source project so random people
have contributed to it so that
microphone noise rooms these are all
problems that you might encounter in the
data set ok so how do we inject audio
into a neural network well
the Wolfram language provides the net
encoders which have wonderful things
that convert more complex data
structures into tensors of numbers which
is the format that neural networks are
usually very happy with and we provide a
reasonably complete collection of
encoder different types of encoders for
audio in this specific example I will
use the audio M FCC encoder and with a
fixed size so this will take an all your
signal and produce a matrix that's 50 by
32 in this specific case and this is
what that kind of data it looked like so
now I mentioned I am using the M FCC
encoder now what does that mean well so
let's talk about quickly about audience
and as I was saying we provide different
types of encoders that perform different
operations on the audio data
let's start with the audio and color the
most simple one it just grabs the sample
values of the signal and puts that into
a n by one matrix so it's just the flat
data that is then passed to the neural
net of course this is not an ideal
representation at first it can be huge
given sample rates of audio and the fact
that it is intrinsically variable length
second we can really exploit all of the
things that we might have learned in
image processing because this is one
dimensional data rather than two
dimensional data so it's convenient to
have in some situations it's definitely
not what we're looking for right now
another encoder is the short time
Fourier transform des partitions the
signal and computes the Fourier
transform on each of the partitions so
you get a 2 dimensional signal that
intrinsically contains both time and
frequency information and this is you
can reconstruct perfectly a signal if
you have the full short time for the
transfer instead if you square all of
these components and discard the
reflected part of the Fourier transforms
the signal is not invertible anymore but
the amount of data that you're dealing
with is still it is much smaller another
variation on the spectrogram is the null
spectrum the idea is pretty simple we
take this time frequency information and
we filter the frequency information with
a nonlinear scale so that we kind of
mimic human perception we don't perceive
the pitch in a linear scale we perceive
pitch in a kind of a logarithmic fashion
and so this volume el spectrogram does a
similar operation another the side
effect of this is that the
dimensionality of the output is reduced
even more with the M FCC we take the
mouth spectrum and do an additional
transformation specifically the cosine
transform and discard some of the higher
our components and and this reduces the
dimensionality of the input further and
this is the result of a lot of classical
signal processing research this is one
of the main feature that was using
classical signal processing operations
before neural networks were a big thing
let's say and the main characteristic is
that it preserves a lot of information
about what is spoken again as I said
while reducing the amount of data that
you will need to analyze so as I was
saying before this is the net encoder
that we chose for our network by the way
incidentally the net encoders that we
provide with the language have a lot of
more functionality one very important
one is the data augmentation so if you
have a small data set you want like if
you are analyzing images during training
you will randomly crop and rotate those
images to artificially augment the data
points that you have to train the data
augmentation in the order of encoders
allows you to do exactly the same thing
and there are some augmentation that are
more simple like time shifting and some
more problem specific like the vocal
tract length of the patient is something
that applies specifically to speech
signals it was I will not going to
details because we have limited time the
other thing that I wanted to mention is
that these net encoders are implemented
in a very efficient way and this is why
you should use these rather than system
functions to inject data internet or
network so on the other side of our
network we need something that converts
the tensor that the network produces the
test of probabilities that the network
produces into a class label and this is
what the net
Corder does so this this is a vector of
probabilities and this will just output
the label which is taken from this list
that was given as input of the decoder
that corresponds to the most probable
[Music]
class four and that specific tensor of
probabilities so what are we doing for
our network let's remember that we have
an encoder that produces a fixed size
matrix so what happens here is simply
flattening our matrix into a single
vector and then this is a simple
multi-layer perceptron which is made up
of fully connected layers which are
matrix multiplications that are then
passed to a non-linearity this is like
essentially the most basic neural
network that you could you could imagine
even though it is extremely simple and
as you can imagine fast to train this
Turk just six seconds I think yes the
results are still pretty impressive well
let's see if my machine actually wants
to scroll down here we go it took about
six seconds within throughput of about
3,000 examples per second we still get
an accuracy of 80 percent the only
knowledge that we injected into this
problem was the fact that we computed
the M FCC features and this is why we
even with such a simple network we can
get such a high accuracy of course we
can do better by using a more
complicated network I was mentioning
before that the incroyable we use
produced fixed sigh mattresses but audio
data is inherently of variable length
the deficit we're using is in head
a variable-length just because it might
take more time to say digit than another
or you might have forgotten to press the
stop button of something like that
so let's enable this variable length
nature of audio by specifying target
length goes to all in the net encoder
and as you can see this produces an
encoder where the matrix size the first
dimension of the matrix is unspecified
so if we try to do to use the same
network we would get a dramatic above
message because our multi-layer
perceptron accept something with a fixed
size so we need to figure out something
else now I don't know how many of you
are familiar with neural networks in
general but in image processing one
typical architecture uses convolutional
layers which perform convolutions
on images now if out of the box
convolution layer does not work on
varying dimension in the Wolfram
language to allow a convolution Network
a conversion layer to operate on data of
varying dimensions the interleaving
options needs to be specified so that
the channel dimension gets pushed as the
last one and the first dimension is the
one that we allow to vary so this is a
again a pretty simple network it has two
convolution layers followed by a
non-linearity and after that the result
is aggregated on the time dimension
let's remember that is the only varying
one so by doing this aggregation we
reduced the output to a fixed size
tensor and then classified with a fully
connected layer again pretty
straightforward network I will not run
this example on my machine just because
we don't have that amount of time
I will show you the result on a GPU
machine this took 20 seconds so not very
much and we without that much effort we
improved the accuracy from about 80% to
slight more than 90% so it's just the
best that we can do using a simple
network on a simple data set well not
necessarily so let's introduce a new
concept that is not used as much in
image processing let's use something
that is that was conceived specifically
for sequence processing not necessarily
all you use is something that is very
popular in for example and LP and stuff
like that you could also use something
like this on images if you set up your
problem in an appropriate way of clear
so we are basing our network on the
gated recurrent layer so what are the
current layers and the idea is pretty
simple we have a simple single set of
weights that are then applied to two
inputs one is the input from the data
and one is the state of the layer at
that time so we apply these weights at
step number one produce an output and in
terminal state and feed those values to
the next step which will receive again
the internal state of the previous time
step and the data at a specific time
step so we can process sequences of
arbitrary length with a very small
number of parameters and this keeps
track of both short and long term
dependencies so there are several layers
that are recurrent that perform the same
kind of operation just with different a
different internal graph for the
operations that are perform
the ones that we have in the language
are basic recurrently gaylord vacuum
layer and long short term memory layer
and of course you can also define your
own using the net fold operator to
create your own custom record and layer
as I was saying this holds a bunch of
trainable parameters and this is an
example of what was processing a
sequence would mean at each step as I
said you get information both from the
input data at time step n and from the
internal state at time step n minus 1
okay so we have our simple network
created using a stack of recurrent
layers I shall just look at that again
and then we just isolate the state the
last internal state of this network and
then we apply a multi-layer perceptron
to this internal state to produce a
single classification so we start with
the variable length sequence tothis it
take the last step of it and then
classify it in one of our 10 classes
this training is actually faster on a
CPU and the convolutional one that we
were looking at before and we get a
comparable accuracy to the conclusion
one with a smaller net and one way to
improve the result that we had right now
is to add some regularization and to the
training and we will do that in the form
of adding dropout for recurrent layers
is the best way to apply dropout in the
training process is to specify the
dropout option inside the definition of
a gala current layer let's look at a
result again
we get immediately an improved accuracy
almost 94% and you might ask is will we
get a better result if we specify more
complicated than that well in this case
that might not be the case just because
of how the data set was collected
because again it was an open source data
set that was contributed by the public
so a lot of well some of the data at
least is bubbly record that also
mislabel this was one example and we by
the way with classifier measurement we
can quickly access and get information
or what were problematic examples this
okay that's well where's silent for
example yeah as I said the data itself
is here the limiting factor of the
accuracy one thing that you can do after
you have trained net is some surgery in
this case for feature extraction you
want to exploit the represent the
internal representation that the net has
produced during the training process -
for example visualize signals in a space
that semantically significant - in the
space of the data set they have trained
the net on in this case we will just
chop off the head of our recurrent
Network and we can use that as the
feature extractor for a future space
plot so you can see how different
signals that contain different digits
are nicely clustered in different parts
of this space and this provides you with
very powerful tools to do computations
numeric computations on complex objects
like audio objects
and I will skip the next example just
because of time and I will go to the
last one the builds on the future
extraction aspect so many times if you
have if the data that you have available
is inadequate to train a network from
scratch to solve a problem one possible
solution can be transferred learning so
instead of training data from scratch
you use another network as a starting
point and the crucial part is that this
network that you're starting with was
trained on a task that is not the same
as the one that your goal is but is a
related task so the features that were
or the internal representation that was
produced while training that network on
the different tasks are still relevant
for the task at hand in this case I will
be using the ESC 50 data set which is
holds a bunch of environmental sounds
these are some examples of classes for
example dogs
roosters pigs or soundscapes or human
sounds interior sounds etc etc the
amount of data is pretty sure that's
just two thousand examples per 50
classes and you can see how the maximum
accuracy that was achieved was about 86%
this is kind of out of out of date this
is just from 2017 the original paper
that presented this data set was
released in 2015
and the region accuracy of 64 percent
training a ComNet from scratch
now we have available from the bottom
positive the audio identify network
which was trained also on a
[Music]
environmental sound recognition task a
sense
on a completely separated data set the
two deficit do not overlap so what we
can do is extract the feature extractor
part of this network which I am doing
here so here we have a net that from
audio signal produces a sequence of
semantically significant feature vectors
and use this as the starting point for
our environmental sound classification
objective instead there are two options
to do this one would be creating a new
network by joining some classification
layers onto this feature extraction
extraction map and then specifying the
learning rate multipliers option in that
train to train only the last layers but
for efficiency reasons we could easily
pre compute all of the features and then
just define a simple classifier which is
done here you can see it's a simple
recurrent layer again we are aggregating
the time dimension and then classifying
that result and train the classifier
that we just defined on the features and
then fuse the two networks together to
get a single result and just with this
very simple net and the training that
takes about one minute and a half we get
an mean accuracy over the that has been
so this is accuracy computed on the
various faults of the data set of 90%
and the joining of the two networks is
extremely simple so these are the two
fused networks and I am doing some and
sampling here and this is the network
has never seen and it is recognized
immediately as a dog so this is one way
of solving a problem a situation where
there is a scarcity of data
and I think with this I will leave the
podium to Marcus we'll talk about images
[Applause]
okay well welcome to this thick second
part of the talk before I start to talk
first of all as I said it's gonna be
more disruptive I'm not gonna tell you
how much so much how things are done or
how what works but what doesn't work and
what's interesting about it and upfront
maybe just to get your attention
there are two ways of learning one is to
learn or to memorize a book essentially
or to read books and to get information
in and to memorize that what's the
second part of learning or the second
way of learning do you know well I may
get intentional second part or the
second way of learning is sex
essentially its evolution and if you are
successful reproducing means that your
brain can't be that bad
you maybe have an advantage and
evolution basically has formed your
brain or rather the architecture of your
brain to do things that you would
otherwise not be able to do for example
there can be a DNA or a deficiency that
you can't recognize faces so it's not
just that you learn how to see faces but
there's a kind of a DNA program that
evolution has formed that enables you
you as a social animal to read faces to
recognize them to see the emotion and so
forth so definitely the architecture and
that's what I'm going to talk about so
the stuff that is sex related that is
just as important as just learning the
way it's the snap tips a synaptic
synapses weights in your network so
let's move move what's going on here
okay here we go all right so this is my
table of contents I'll be talking about
four different opt issues first of all
just to start up on a positive note I
will show you how effective or how great
computer convolution on your networks
are and what they can achieve
essentially there are from a statistical
point of view a very good prior to
natural images then I'm gonna break
everything down I'll show you how to
fool neural networks
show the shortcomings a kind of an
interlude I will talk a bit about
Anatomy how the brain does it and then I
will show some let's say unorthodox ways
to handle image recognition first to
write an image encoder pretty much like
what we have for audio and then last but
not least I'll talk about the latest
invention by Geoffrey Hinton one of the
grant godfathers of new networks what he
baptized caps net alright so the deep
image prior as I said in statistics one
you basically tackle a new distribution
then maybe the a priori knowledge that
you have about that distribution is
called the prior and it seems to be that
computer convolutional neural nets have
a kind of a prior for natural images and
I quickly like to explain why that is if
you have a newer network like a vanilla
neural network the net or whatever that
basically applies convolutions and
another layer and another layer till you
basically classify your input you can
just turn it around
and also have neural networks that
generate images from a kind of a state
vector said you could do that in a very
uneffective way by having fully
connected layers that's what I have
basically depicted here on the top but
that is kind of very costly with respect
to connections and weights that you
would have to learn so typical
convolutional layer what are sorry a
fully connected layer is as of the order
of millions of weights then you can do
bit better by saying oh well usually
images they have a property that only
images that are image or parts of the
image that are nearby that they are
closely related or correlated so there's
no need to connect the left bottom of
your image with the right top of the
image so let's just do the connections
in a neighborhood environment so that
would impose a kind of a partially
connected layer we just connect neurons
that are and within a certain
neighborhood and then becomes the next
idea of images and that is an image is
usually constructed in a similar fashion
of the bottom left as on the top right
so there is no well there you have a
kind of a mu genius construction
setup or paradigm that certain areas in
an image are not completely treated
different than other areas so that means
that whatever you learn for let's say
the bottom left corner for your image
should also be applicable for the top
right
so essentially you can do a convolution
you just learn a kernel so just the
neighborhood of connections and then
translate that across the entire image
and that's essentially what a
convolutional net is and if we were to
build now just a convolution Network but
just turn it upside down by not applying
convolutions but what's called D
convolutions in a way inverse
convolutions you start with a small
state vector and then generate an image
and this would be such a network in
Mathematica as a leaky really we can
also work with a normal rectifying
linear unit and you see here you start
with just a state vector of three times
three times 28 128 parameters and then
you deconvolve deconvolve it until you
spit out at the end an image so
essentially you can see that network
just as a function f that depends on
lots of lots of parameters and the
parameters are the weights in that
network so it's just essentially when I
learn now how to generate an image it's
nothing else but fitting a function a
function valve that doesn't have two or
three parameters but in the order of
this case of our roughly 300 and what is
it 350 1000 parameters so two rather
tedious fit but clearly I can fit any
image because an image like this one
here 256 x 256 just as of the order of a
24 eight 248,000 pixel values it means
three values per pixel essentially so if
I now take this bird in and if I train
here that layer the generation net then
the learning curve would look like this
it goes down nicely so it does fit and
effectively if I look at the result oh
sorry I can look at the result but I
won't do that right now because it's
nothing important right now we just see
that the network can learn the
representation of the image
if we do that very same for an image
that is now somewhat yeah unnatural in
the sense that it has lots of noise I
just added pessoa noise to that image
then we see that again I can fit that
very a neural network onto the image but
if you compare the two fits the two lost
plots you will see that the image with
the noise at the very bottom I should
bring it up a bit let's see that the one
with noise fits much less well less well
than the one that was a completely
natural image so apparently
convolutional networks or d
convolutional networks have a tendency
to go for natural-looking images so in a
way they have a prior for natural images
and we can take an advantage of that
actually this was a paper by early
enough and others who said well is that
so if we have a natural prior for
natural images then we can use it for
example for denoising
I won't show the code the code by the
way and just include you don't have to
read it now so that you can experiment
with this notebook when you download it
so please forgive me if we're having
lots of code in my slides and what you
can do is basically just fit an image
and then if you break off then usually
the image will have fitted the
natural-looking part of the image and
not the noise yet and this you can use
them for denoising an image as one
possible application or what you could
do is and again I just hide most of the
detail here you can go and do what's
called in painting so imagine you have
an image like this and I cut part of
that image out because I just want to in
paint it I just run again this network
and it tries to generate a
natural-looking image without this
artificial cut out part of which is by
the way it happens to be a vase and then
you run it oops this is the wrong sorry
ah shoot it did okay I'm sorry I
rendered again apparently and it saved
the wrong result you have felt in
an implanted image just like implant in
in mathematica sorry accidentally
rendered again and I have took the wrong
step size maybe just as a kind of a side
remark this very much depends on the
optimization that you use sometimes it
goes bad sometimes it goes well but the
port is you can use that prior even to
in pain all right
having said that basically I've said the
conclusion images or network networks
the architecture is really good for
images as such all the different types
that you have nowadays are optimized not
just the way or the capability of
capturing images but just to be better
in to be more easily optimized for
example so that's another aspect which I
won't touch now however I just recap a
little example that I think presented a
year or two ago just a very quick recap
your neural networks are also easily
fooled and what I'm doing here is the
following I just load one of our first
image identify networks as the inception
be one version one trained on the
competition data of imagenet and if I
provide to this network for example an
image of a cockroach or tiger I get
those identified with fairly high
probability or confidence cockroach here
with 96 96 percent confidence a tiger
was 73 percent confidence so quickly
schematically what was done on this CNN
this convolutional neural network the
inception network is basically depicted
by this symbol here and we essentially
train it not just on tiger so we provide
an image tiger and then say the output
text should be tiger we are trying to
optimize that we try to optimize that
for cockroach and lots and lots of other
images that's how this thing is trained
but now at the end we'll do something
completely different now we say okay we
keep cockroach we try to optimize the
output cockroach we don't do anything to
the network keep all the weights fixed
but instead we start to train the image
so the image basically now read in or
in front of the network just as a new
network layer with the weights being the
values of the image and then I say to
net train just train that very first
layer don't train anything else so what
I would expect now doing so is that I
changed that Tiger down here in such a
way that it doesn't give out or it
doesn't optimize the output for Tiger
but optimizes now the output for
cockroach because that's the lost
function that I try to optimize for or
to lower so having said that this is
essentially just dissecting the network
putting an new loss function attaching
that the well actually could quickly run
this this doesn't take for long is
running all of this quickly and so if I
train it now you can see that the loss
goes down the error is almost 100% and
then suddenly it switches which
basically means suddenly it gets the
idea okay I don't end up with Tiger
anymore but I switch over to cockroach
as as a result is a classification so at
the end of the day I just take then the
first layer and just weed out the first
layer of that network and you see well
it looks like a tiger it looks so much
like a tiger that you can't imagine that
the new network now we classify that as
a cockroach I can quickly demonstrate
that here I put it through the so this
is Tiger - I put it into the network and
you see cockroach with 67% probability
but would have run even further would
have gotten almost 99% so looking at the
difference there's very little different
than what you see maybe it's different
it's very high spatial has a very high
spatial frequency so then we can figure
out that by blurring it for example I
get back to tiger I can also apply
different your network it wouldn't be
fooled but the point here is that we see
that neural networks are subject to what
I would call visual illusion optical
illusion is and misnomer it's a visual
illusion just like humans can go
it can be tricked by whatever but they
are tricked by other phenomena than this
new network so there's clearly a
difference between our visual system and
what convolutional neural networks do
and that's why I quickly move over to
explain a little bit of the anatomy of
the human visual system to relate to
that in what I'm gonna say later okay so
basically at the back of the eye you're
you look or your receive images on your
retina and the retina roughly speaking
looks essentially like this when it
comes to receptive fields so all the
cones and rods they are basically
grouped together to excite our ganglion
cell and then would convey that signal
onward and less ganglion cell is
connected to all these rods and cones in
such a way that you have kind of a
receptive field sensitivity distribution
that is different in size depending on
where you are on the retina so if you're
on the phobia in the center of your
visual acuity then you have very small
receptive fields so you have a high
resolution if you're further out you
basically have large receptive fields
resulting and a low resolution image
which basically means that you as a
human being
besides moving around constantly that's
a different topic altogether you look at
images not just as the finest possible
resolution but at all kinds of scales
which currently in many cases we don't
do with our convolution on your networks
we read in the highest resolution and
try to make sense of that then once you
get that information it's being
transported to the back of your brain to
your via the LGN to your visual cortex
and if you have a look at your visual
cortex
it's like the sheet of the your brain
your cortex sheet then you will see that
there is an encoding of your stimulus on
your retina that roughly mimics the
spatial distribution so if you are get a
white light spot on the top right it
ends up on the top bottom here in this
visual cortex and vice versa so you have
a spatial encoding but on top of it
you also take difference between
receptive fields so you detect edges or
lines and thereby orientation and you
also encode orientation in the receptive
field something that we don't do at all
in our or currently in our convolutional
networks
and this orientation is just one of the
many intrinsic parameters that you have
in the visual cortex between seeing
something on the left eye the right eye
and so forth so just pointing out that
there is just more than just a location
to a stimulus and furthermore just as a
kind of reminder that things get really
weird once the information leaves the
visual cortex then you have a kind of a
pathway that's called the ventral
pathway that it's basically does what
convolutional neural networks do fairly
well it tells you what it is so that
would be that pathway in the brain and
then there's another pathway of
information it's the where pathway the
dorsal pathway that's basically more
processing where something is so clearly
with the neural network of the brain on
the other end codes position in a way
that we don't do in convolutional
networks either
all right so having said all that the
first thing I would like to quickly
discuss is how would I go about to for
example mimic the retina we have seen
with the audio our samples that there is
an audio and card in in our framework
not just one but several different ones
that take the audio signal and convert
it to a more digestible format like a
Fourier transformation essentially a
wavelet transformation but we don't do
anything like that in image processing I
remember the early days people said well
don't mimic or don't fiddle around with
any kind of old-school image processing
features because you're most likely to
mess up the data you're going to lose
information and you just let the neural
network alert all the features all the
information all the features in in an
image to a certain degree it's true but
you also have to have lots of data in
order to do that furthermore when you
train a network it transfers the top
layer which is close to the class
classification and slowly their training
descends all the way to the bottom layer
that's closest to the data so that layer
gets trained last and you need lots of
data to get good good weights down there
so the idea quite frankly is why not
build an image encoder pretty much like
an audience and
if we can do okay even better than
anticipated and in a way unroll a little
bit of the development of image
processing in the last eight years so
upfront what I do here this is just a
mathematical gig I take an image like
one and they imagine you are still an
ape living in the jungle your retina
gets trained and essentially if those
radio bases receptive fields to be ideal
from a mathematical standpoint of view
they should be eigenfunctions on all
those little patches that you can
possibly see in your visual field and
this is basically quickly what I do
mathematically here I partition this
image into 16 x 16 little sub images
then I generate a weight function that
just the case with a way to the edges so
that there are not have boundary effects
doing these small images so I have kind
of a yeah it's almost like a Gaussian
distribution of weights that I put on
this little patch and then I just
essentially find the eigenfunctions the
eigenvectors of these patches and
without having to calculate this which
would take just a few minutes I would
get from such an image this election of
possible receptive fields that would be
mathematically optimal to decode your
image with in order to process it even
further so the question is can we do
something similar here it could be a
group in a basis you can call it a gob
or wavelets there there are lots of
different mathematical entities that
very much look alike so they all claim
to be the one so I'm not going to that
in that debate but perfect point to make
so ok so whatever I do I'll just
construct my own little weight functions
mathematically and upfront we'll have to
make sure is that when I transpose or
basically move or shift them along
because I essentially do a convolution
with these kernels I want to make sure
that I my weight function that I use
covers the entire space evenly and in
order to do so I take here as a weight
functions b-splines because they have
this nice property
to add up to one if you just shift them
a certain amount and if you add them all
up to up together and they overlap then
essentially you get precise weight of
one across the whole domain and for
every bin or every pixel or cone that is
sample you would get these kind of
weights and having this weight I can
define a kind of an inner product and
then I do something that you may know
from orthogonal polynomials I have known
inner product I can just generate now a
basis that is awful normal with respect
to this inner product and if I do so I
essentially get these kind of orthogonal
functions or under this weight
distribution and I used those to
generate now my kernels and these are
just a collection of all those possible
distributions you can get and they look
very much like in this case garbo
functions but essentially these are in a
way derivatives of a Gaussian Tower and
you can combine them if you want you're
just pointing out for example this the
third the second and the third one you
can combine and rotate them as a
gradient the third fourth and fifth
sorry the fourth fifth and six you can
combine as a kind of a rich detector so
line detector which you can rotate and
so forth so any linear combination of
that basis would be fine as well and
then just go and say well what the heck
are trained now a new network first of
all without redefining the first layer
I'll do that and then I get these kind
of kernels in the first layer so that's
what's being learned it's a little bit
you see certain resembles like this it's
like an edge detector there should be a
blob detector somewhere here like here
so essentially it does the same but
without having too much data they don't
turn out to be that great but if I plug
now my constructed my constructed
receptive fields into the first
convolutional layer by simply saying
take as weights these kernels don't add
a bias and just do the very same thing
train the whole stuff and it trains
nicely and then I can do the following I
can compare the training plots hold on
here we go and what you see here is the
following you see the lost plot and the
error plot of the training the blue is
the training without the constructed
layer and the red is the one with
constructed layer and it's amazing that
because essentially we have the most
perfect bases up front we do better than
just learning on data so maybe the long
run there will be a kind of an image
encoder for images just like this for
audio because you can achieve better
results essentially all right so that's
message number one message number two I
only have six minutes left which is yeah
those are locked so it's basically just
like an encoder it's not exactly it's in
a way constructed transfer learning yeah
you know transfer construction you
didn't learn you theoretically
constructed these okay another problem
that your networks have and which is
predominant in the human visual thinking
is the binding that your visual cortex
does when it comes to objects that you
see for example here I what do you see I
assume you all see a triangle
strictly speaking there's no triangle
but you bind all these wedges together
to a triangle and as soon as I just mess
up the alignment slightly the triangle
is gone yeah it's you don't bind it
anymore but so that's something a
conversion on your network wouldn't be
able to do and this optical illusion you
may all know some of you may see an old
woman the more lucky ones they see a
young woman and if you look closely you
can switch forth and back so it's a
binding problem what you attribute to
what for example if you see a young
woman and this is the nose
these are eyelashes this is a year if
you see the old woman this is an eye
this is an eye but this whole chin is
the nose and down here the necklace is a
mouth so depending how you bind things
you see different things that means when
you learn or see something you not only
have an up forward forward
feed-forward network but you also have a
some feedback and that's a little bit
what caps net by Geoffrey Hinton which
was introduced two years ago hat in mind
the big first big change is so far we
always assumed that one neuron stands
for one feature that you detect like an
edge nose and eye so the activation of
one neuron in your neural network
basically in quotes one feature but when
you look at the brain
it looks more like there's a whole
column of up to 80 or more neurons in
your in the sheet of your brain that
encodes together one feature so it's not
just one year but several neurons and is
there more than one neuron you can
actually have inner state and that's why
instead of using neurons
the idea is to substitute them in a way
by capsules capsules basically standing
for several neurons so such a neuron
cannot have just one activation what
they have several activations so
essentially you assign one year into one
feature you treat the activities of all
the neurons in that capsule as a vector
the norm of the vector of the length of
the vectors basically stands for the
probability of that feature being there
but and that is new
you have now an orientation of that
vector and that orientation basically
can encode intrinsic parameters like if
you have an edge intrinsic parameter
would be the where and the orientation
if you have an eye the orientation or
the intrinsic parameter may be the scale
how close the eyes to you what color it
has and so forth so we can encode
internal parameters then instead of
having a non-linearity function Sigma a
real or whatever we have a squash
function which essentially does this to
a vector it normalizes it to something
between 0 and 1 and has a kind of
nonlinear shape and then last but not
least when you pass
a vector activity of one capsule on to
the next capsule essentially can
possibly do a linear transformation T
doing so so just to quickly compare now
what the differences are between the
capsule network and your network capsule
the activities are scalar you have just
one value per neuron for capsule II
actually have an entire vector when you
pass activities along from one year on
to the next you just take the scalar
value and pass it along for a capsule
you may have to learn a transformation
then when you actually attach your
activity to the next neuron next capsule
you do waiting you do the same for
capsules and then the activation
function could be any Sigma here
non-linearity here it's a squashed
function and again the output is a
vector again alright so how does it look
like there's one extra feature and that
is interesting part about the binding
issue is that in this capsule and
network if you have an activation which
is here now you have a capsule here one
down here lower layer and then the upper
layer you have another capsule if the
orientation of the vector is the same
once you transport it from here to here
then that connection the weights here
are strengthened so if the line of the
properties align your connection
strengthens if they don't align no
matter how active this thing is they are
the connection decreases so there's a
slightly different learning and this is
iterated two or three times and this has
called dynamic routing because it
basically enforces this kind of binding
issue that I outlined that you would
learn about an year and another year
they basically are in a position that
fits to a nose or her entire face then
they bind otherwise they don't and okay
why did I tell you all of this last
minute we have the caps net on our
repository so you can fool around with
it and that's what I'd like to entice
here in this talk so this is a net caps
net model that is trained on again
endless data because it's small and easy
to Train essentially here you have
capsules first you have a simple
convolution
then those features go into one capsule
to the next capsule layer and then
essentially you figure out how long the
vectors are in these capsules these are
by the way fully connected capsular
networks and then you take the norm and
this gives you the classification so
this is what you optimize but on top of
it and that's a little bit extra you
have to also learn the internal
properties and for that you have to
attach to the output a network that
takes the vectors and then tries to
reconstruct the original image with
these vectors so with the properties you
try to reconstruct the original image
and if you're good doing so you also
learn the internal features the internal
intrinsic parameters of that network so
it's a little bit more refined when it
comes to training and well it has been
pre trained so I can just run it on a
sample of these network of these numbers
who have one six seven seven eight I get
the right classification and on top of
it gives you the reconstructions of
these digits and it's a nice thing to
have I'll explain a bit more about this
here's a confidence you can also cut off
the rest and then create just like with
a normal CN and a feature space maybe I
shouldn't have done this this takes a
little bit long I'll just cut it here so
this is a three dimensional feature
space and you see the nice grouping that
I have achieved here but on top of it I
have this Reconstructor and that means I
can take those vectors of those capsules
that make up a 1 or 2 and I can change
them so I can extract first of all the
Reconstructor network that has been
burned long and then I can change parts
of that intrinsic vector and you can see
that that vector for example here for 6
changes at 6 to a different shape if you
change another parameter in that
intrinsic parameter vector the thickness
of the six changes for example or if you
go here you see that actually the slant
changes so naturally not only learn
objects like a CNN but you're on top of
it learn their properties and that also
helps at the end for example if you have
none
that are superimposed and you have to
basically make connections then you have
to have these properties and then it can
meet here nine zero and here you can
actually read at the end that there is a
nine and a zero present present at the
same time something that would fail or
is more likely to fail it split this way
when you just take a vanilla the net
approach on end list then in this case
it would rather read a two at a zero
instead of a nine all right so I'm sorry
for going slightly over time I hope I
gave you lots of ideas maybe raised more
questions and the idea of this talk was
not so much to teach about Mathematica
on your networks but just to basically
run ideas besides so beside you so that
you have more lust to go for it and to
figure out what one can change and what
one can study thank you
[Applause]